while the journalists at fake news cnn
msdnc
obsessively worry about all of that
dangerous freedom that exists in
states like florida and texas well in
new york city
their mayor comrade bill de blasio just
announced
a city-wide vaccine passport mandate
these are the new rules anyone that
wants to dine indoors
or go to a gym or do pretty much
anything inside
you'll need to present documents proving
that you have been
vaccinated remember for months now
democrats insisted that
well all forms of voter id yeah they're
racist they called
voter verification voter id laws jim
crow of the 21st century and jim crow
2.0 but apparently identification for
daily activities is democratic approved
just like attending the dnc i want to
see your congressman or woman or senator
from your state
or getting a bottle of wine or a six
pack of beer yeah you need photo id
and now they want you to have
identification to prove that you have
been vaccinated
just to enter a restaurant but not to
vote
now today biden praised de blasio's
efforts
now something to keep in mind there is a
new york statistics that show
only 33 percent of african americans in
new york city are vaccinated a low rate
now this means that under comrade de
blasio's rules
that would mean 66 percent fully
two-thirds of
african-americans will be barred from
restaurants from concerts
from venues where you have ballgames
from
gyms movie theaters all in new york city
this will now negatively and quite
disproportionately impact
minorities in new york city and by the
way what about medical exemptions
in other words maybe your doctor says
you shouldn't get
the shot shouldn't get the vaccine
because of this rare condition or that
rare condition
what about the cleveland clinic and
following their science
highly respected medical institution
they said if you have covert you don't
need any vaccine
and never mind medical privacy your
medical privacy never mind your
doctor patient confidentiality anyone
who is vaccinated
is allowed to attend indoor activities
while they'll now soon have to
share their personal medical documents
with
employees at every restaurant every bar
every sporting event every concert
and other random strangers all across
new york city
and sadly new york's vaccine passports
is just one
of the draconian measures that are now
being implemented now nationwide
vaccine mandates are now in effect for
government workers in new york and
california
indoor mass mandates has just been
reinstated in the
sanctuary city of san francisco and los
angeles and washington d.c
and dozens of other cities a mass
mandate for the military
has also been reinstated they're
considering mandatory vaccinations for
the military
federal officials also calling on
children as young as
three years old to wear masks at all
times
in school that might be task impossible
colorado they're now ordering children
to stay six feet apart from one another
and practice social distancing at all
times there are also new vaccine
mandates new testing requirements
for all federal contractors and get this
on cnn fake news today the nih director
actually instructed parents you better
be wearing masks around
your children in your home take a look
the recommendations are for kids under
that they avoid being in places where
they might get infected which means
recommendations of mask wearing in
schools
and that at home our parents of
unvaccinated kids
should be thoughtful about this and the
recommendation is to wear masks there as
well let me just follow up i know that's
uncomfortable i know it seems
weird but it is the best way to protect
your kids
now the naih director did try later to
backtrack right after that interview
because of the backlash
but who real who knows what he really
believes at this point
the so-called experts in our federal
government they seem to have different
messages on masks and treatments
and vaccines every day a new a new
protocol
how is that not confusing and they're
they're asking where vaccine hesitancy
comes from
that would be from them from joe biden
on down
and according to the contradictory
statements from biden
lockdowns may or may not be coming back
now remember just a few weeks ago when
biden fauci
and everyone else in the government they
were promising all of us right they were
promising you
your life would return to normal if you
got the vaccine
that they not having gone to medical
school or done a residency or an
internship or ever practiced medicine
that they are telling everybody to get
it without any knowledge of anybody's
own medical history or current medical
condition
anyway were they just lying or naive
you decide so if we can get the
overwhelming
proportion of the population vaccinated
by let's say the end of the second the
beginning of the third quarter
by the time we get into mid-fall of 2021
we could be approaching some level of
normality
what does 70 mean it means that we can
now
return to life as we know it
the biggest takeaway is that getting
vaccinated is our ticket
back to normal we need of course to keep
up the effort to inoculate the rest of
the country
but suffice it to say we are well on our
way to bringing the country
out of chaos out of crisis and back
to normal the vaccines are about saving
your life
but also the lives of the people around
you
but they're also about helping to get us
get back to closer to normal in our
living
more normal living now
never mind the same people who were
eager to lock us
all down at the drop of a hat it went
from
vaxxed or mass to vax and mass to
vaccine passports
to mandatory vaccinations with social
distancing
and mom and dad wearing masks at home
except at the border
there's a big exception here where
illegal immigrants
are now pouring across into this country
in record numbers the highest numbers in
25 years
nobody's being tested no vaccinations
are being given out
and then the administration is now
pretty much dispersing
all of these illegal immigrants all over
the country
yep non-tested most unvaccinated
and some without so much as even an
examination
never mind a covid test according to
biden texas governor greg abbott florida
governor ron desantis are actually
responsible
for the spike in government cases he's
blaming them
like he blames trump for the immigration
crisis that's a joke
because they're refusing to enact tough
restrictions in
their states those states have done
phenomenally well without draconian
shutdowns
and of course biden's poll numbers well
they're now
tanking a majority of americans do not
even think that joe biden is really in
charge
that speaks volumes considering the rest
of the media mob
they're never going to show you the
cognitive mess that joe biden really is
like we do
but whoever is running the show over
there whether it's the fail border czar
or kamala harris or chief of staff ron
claim who knows maybe barack obama i
don't know
or the cdc or the teachers union that
writes policy for the cdc
this country is headed in what is a very
very scary direction
as biden's dark winter now turns into
biden's dark summer dark
fall and dark perpetuity hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else